you
hello and welcome from the royal swedish
academy of sciences where we just
discovered who's received the 2008 nobel
prize in chemistry joining me to discuss
this applies more detail it was the last
two lambda plus 2 lambda thank you very
much for agreeing to talk and why so
soon after announced has been laid could
we begin by you telling us who has
received the 2008 they're mobilizing
chemistry well it's it's given to sri
memoria champion cam for their discovery
and enrollment of the green fluorescent
protein gfp and so the green fluorescent
protein or gfp has been described in the
announcements as as an achievement that
has a similar impact in science the
microscope has had well described by
that sign yes the great thing with gfp
is that it is a tool that makes it
possible to start the metabolism or
reactions inside a living cell without
destroying you know the classical way
for biochemistry was to crush the cell
extract it put into test tube and try to
find out different reactions and so on
but now you can label your protein of
interest very easily any students can do
that and then you can start it what
happens to the protein inside the living
cell when the cell is born when it
divides when it metabolizes and so on
and that is a very good position you can
look at the individual molecules and
that has completely changed the field of
biomedicine so this is a fluorescent tag
or a marker that you can put on any
protein you're particularly interested
in and track its movement through cells
over time through the course of an
organism yeah
right and so this is obviously expanded
the world of that we can see it within
cells could you give us an example of
what we can now see thanks to gfp when
they shown in the introduction here for
example what happens when HIV viruses
infects a cell and when the cells don't
reproduce new bars because we can lay
with the coat protein of the virus with
gfp and then you infect the cell and you
can see first how the cell is diffusely
green but then with time you see small
very green spots that assembles wrote
the same that the new virus is a form
and you can done in real time follow how
fast they are built and how this
assembly is made and then of course you
can start to understand how you put
interfere with this assembles in a more
detailed than you could ever do before
she did so this is open up and you won't
fall for short yes I guess worldwide if
you follow the scientific literature in
the last ten years or so he just explode
every second paper has screen
information protein or something similar
in it that's a method yes so the prize
itself as was awarded three researchers
who involved in different stages and
discovery and development of gfp if we
could could we go through each one in
turn place and discuss the key
discoveries behind all there so if we
started the person who actually
discovered gfp in the first place that
was the japanese shimomura and he was
basically into it was a marine biologist
and he was interested in bioluminescence
and that's the reaction where you can
create light without heat it's a
chemical reaction that gives off line
and you can see it in
different and fireflies song you can see
it in lots of animals living in the sea
you can see how they flourish if you'd
all the night they use it to signal
between each other and he was interested
to know exactly what control this
reaction and the chemical background for
it so he started to isolate it start to
collect this money and it sucked Loria
victoria it is the jellyfish so he
collected hundreds and hundreds of this
yellow fish in the friday harbor at the
west coast of america and then they cut
out the light organs that are deserted
the borders of the yellow fish and
collected lots and lots of these and
extracted them and purified the enzyme
that was responsible for their for the
light emission and then you could show
that if you look at the sea you can see
that the jellyfish has a green
fluorescent light but when you isolated
this by illumination enzyme you got the
blue line so obviously something was
missing and then he looked again and he
found this green fluorescent protein
that transfers the blue light into green
light and that must be an advantage for
the yellow fish maybe you can see them
in longer distance you can tell it apart
from other fishes
and then off so so he really isolating
the green fluorescent protein made the
manor sequence amino acid sequence of it
and he also identified the chromophore
which is three amino acids inside sort
of a barrel and then for the chromophore
that makes a green fluorescent light
when you irradiate be blue light so that
was his partner so so professor Shiva
Morin discovered the protein that glows
in jellyfish the next step was described
as Eureka Byzantine Alistair's of course
nothing happened for one because people
assumed from other systems that to get
the green fluorescent protein
fluorescein you need some other enzyme
systems to create the chromophore
because there are lots of similar
systems known earlier so then they clone
this game for the green Russian pole
position rival in that and he tried to
express it but he saw an alteration and
that was his expectation I thought well
of course it wouldn't work because you
need some other enzyme also from from
the jellyfish to get the floor esha so
stopped at that level for a while but
then came in the guy who left his child
Heena who was interested in elegance
this nematode that s model system for
North development source only one
millimeter long organism and he was very
interested to have a reporter for him
expression and he heard about this green
fluorescent protein so let's try so he
had a rotation student very you know I
she didn't know anything but she got
this gene and expressed and sure
immediately so that it formed a green
fresh and light and in charge we tried
both in e.coli bacteria and in the
nematode and in both cases if your rash
and of course they draw the conclusion
and published which is very important
that you don't need anything else you
only need this protein it forms the
chromophore itself and that was
completely on our dough so that was the
revolution so saying so the key to this
was the gfp by itself glowed without
without the police or it's also by their
health and that was completely new and
then and the other important thing was
that you could actually take take this
this fluorescent protein put it into
other organisms switch on the genes for
it to create the protest it still
wouldn't live and then the protein forms
this barrier and the chromophore visor
it only needs oxia so you have to have
in organism which use oxygen but most
organized nice so that's the only and
then you form this before and so and
that of course when people heard about
that that spread around in circles this
is great but then come in Jem who was
the man that made it to a useful tool
because it was still rather primitive it
wasn't very bright and it wasn't very
stable and so on but he made mutations
in it and then developed it into a very
good tool that anybody can use and he
also expanded the colors
the only green from the beginning now
you have all the ways from blue to red
and that's important when you want to
start in many proteins at the same time
in a Cell you can have one red one blue
one green is over then you can see how
they interact during the cell life
because you can follow them and in euros
you can see how this different nerve
cells one sense of the green spot to
sprout and one red one and how veins the
correctness or six immensely important
and so and what what this allow people
to do is to work on different organisms
work on different tissues analyze the
sort of a very complex level of protein
expression see what proteins are
different space and time and to where we
now with Whitney's is proteins what what
what can we see well I mean lots of
optic methods that were invented during
the 1980s and so on they couldn't really
be used because nobody know how to make
good for ration marcussen right now
because they have been revived and there
are many fancy names on this between can
measure distances between proteins you
can you can try and lie to those you can
sort of put one for ration dr. you start
and other variations you have very good
possibilities to follow processing the
cell goes in time and in space and see
exactly what happens when the cell is
metabolizing dying leaving us all and
that is very powerful so what what's
happened is we've we've moved over 40
years from someone who's looking at a
very basic curiosity like how did
jellyfish glow expect you to a
biomedical revolution right a Nobel
Prize and of course nobody could have
said that earlier but but now it's a
very good tool and you know it gets more
and more fashion now to look at single
molecules early we could use
because you have no signals you have to
have many molecules to see and then you
get averages but now when you can label
your favorite program will be in
terrestrial you can start in one
molecule at the time and then you can
really understand how an enzyme works
and you don't just see the mean of
hundred enzyme you see exactly what
tested what comes up and goes down and
how genes are put on and off physics
like this you can see how things work
normally but also how things work in
disease yeah sure and then you can
compare the season you know different
metabolic states and when the cell
divides and all the sourcing you can see
in one single molecule podcast is
molecule doing this is great